всім привіт вміємо по даня про
так званий проект змін у
конституцію щодо децентралізації ну
класична історія вселенського ще
називається про децентралізацію на самому
справі про повну централізацію та про те
яким чином носить задовольнити путіна
тихесенько і без змін до конституції
щоб не треба було 300 голосів набирати
фактично що пропонується що ви
верховна рада 226 голосами могла дати
будь-якій громаді під будь-якій громаді будь-кому
місту та будь-якій області спеціальний
правовий статус 2 ходівка спочатку
зміна конструкцію а потім наприклад
донецької області спеціальний статус
без будь-яких змін у конструкцію 300
голосів
вже не треба, але чим зовсім за дурнів нас
всіх тримають ще й знищують
де-факто місцеве самоврядування
крім того, президент може взяти і
фактично розформувати будь-який
міську обласну раду призначити
свого представника загалом можна
взагалі вже
нікому не обиратися, коли є за це
більше ніхто не потрібний він там ззаду прапор
україни ось цей історичний прапор
які вносили у дев'яносто першому році
ну вже за нього хоче знаєте замінити на
якийсь свій прапор на якому просто
буде написано за і роблю що хочу
не можна це допустити боремося все буде
Україна